One method of saving a GPU computations is to bake the lighting into the
surfaces themselves. Say I have a scene with a bunch of a defused subjects, each
with its own material color and with the surface normals stored at the vertices.
If i can compute the shade of the object once and store this color instead of
the normal. I can save on lighting calculations each frame. As before assume
every light is very far away, but that it can change direction, just as the
sun's angle to the ground changes direction over time. The vertex shader
normally takes as input the position of the object, in other words, the vertex's
location. And it also takes in the normal and lights that want to be applied to
the surface. The output is the screen position and an RGB color. Instead of
storing the surface normal, under what exact conditions could I safely compute
the lighting once, and store an RGB color at each vertex? Your first choice is,
if the object orientation does not change. By object orientation I mean whether
the object is rotating. If the eye position and lights' directions do not change
is your second choice. If the lights' directions and object orientation do not
change. And finally if the eye position and object orientation do not change.
So, which of these answers is the one that allows you to precompute an RGB per
vertex and use that, instead of having to do lighting calculations each frame?